right these are massive and huge
breaking developments tonight about what
a severe Obama era FISA abuses this
letter just released tonight to the
Attorney General jeff Sessions the house
Intel committee chair Devon Nunez is
detailing how the FBI may have literally
broken the law and violated Bureau
protocols when a painting that FISA
warrant to surveil Trump campaign
associate Carter page now in this letter
released tonight Nunez points out
specific DOJ guidelines when it comes to
FISA surveillance he writes quote under
the subsection FISA verification and
accuracy procedures the FBI itself
acknowledges this importance quote the
accuracy of information contained within
FISA applications is of the utmost
importance only documented and verified
information may be used to support FBI
applications FISA warrants to the court
given this new information chairman
Nunez he is now demanding the DOJ
explain if in fact these protocols are
still in place we already know the
answer they never verified this and if
they are the chairman wants to know how
officials will be punished for violating
this law lying to a FISA judge and not
following protocol this letter also
points out how using this false
information in a FISA Court could
violate several laws look at them on the
screen 18 USC 242 using color of law to
conduct a targeted investigation based
on the pretext of law enforcement then
you have 50 USC 1809 surveillance
conducted under color of law in a manner
not authorized by a FISA conspiracy
obstruction of justice and contempt of
court what this means is the scandal is
getting bigger and bigger unlike an
abuse of power we have ever seen in the
history of this country that's why we
are impelling layer after layer of this
onion Greg Jarrah Sarah Carter jason
Chaffetz the great one Mark Levin will
all have reaction to this tonight and
also breaking we have more evidence the
Democrats Trump Russia collusion
narrative for 20 months as a complete
farce
Democratic congressman Adams
you know the ranking member of the house
in telemental Trump Haider
he's now admitting that the scary
damning earth-shattering information
that he has now been playing up for more
than a year is already in the public
domain really where is it watch this you
said you had more than circumstantial
evidence of treasonous collusion with
Russia what specifically were you
referring to and please be specific
because if it's true I do believe
Americans have the right to know a year
later what that is certainly said that
there's ample evidence of collusion I've
never used the word treason only Steve
Bennett has used that word but if you
look at the the facts that are already
in the public domain they're pretty
damning for Muller to bring charges
because if it isn't enough for Muller to
bring charges what does that mean well
what did we know charges this is a very
important question and that is what's
Muller's job and what's our job Bob
Muller will make the decision whether
there is proof beyond a reasonable doubt
- and indict and convict people he it is
not his responsibility to tell the
country what happened
amazing job Megan McCain let me give you
the translation Adam Schiff is accusing
Trump of collusion with little more than
speculation rumor and a phony Russian
dossier that was never corroborated or
verified do you see how severe this is
now we may well find out in coming weeks
or months that shifts constant
anti-trump five alarm fires has been
nothing more than political hyperbole
meant to damage a sitting president that
you voted for so he could win favor with
his liberal base and get hired by
conspiracy TV MSNBC and it's probably
why according to the RNC
Schiff has appeared on television 227
times
since president Trump's inauguration so
it's only a matter of time where NBC
hires them maybe it'll take over from
Matt Lauer who's been out for a while
also brand new tonight Robert Muller now
facing criticism from someone who has
intimate knowledge of special counsel
investigations can it start you might
remember independent counsel responsible
for investigating Bill Clinton in the 90
he is saying that Muller something we've
been saying might be crossing a line
watch this
Bob Mullin looking into Trump's business
dealings before 2016 to see if there was
potential opportunity for exertion of
influenced by Russian uh any kind of
actors on their part fair point
I think it's beyond his mandate the
mandate is what happened during the 2016
election in terms of collusion in fact I
think that the indictment almost two
weeks ago of the thirteen Russian
nationals and the three companies
suggest there was no collusion my sense
would be but I don't have all the facts
Bob I love you but let's just stay
focused on what the issue is and that's
collusion in the campaign star went on
to explain that what Muller's
investigation must remain narrowly
focused it's up to the Deputy Attorney
General he's right rod Rosenstein who is
overseeing this case to keep Muller on
task they'll remember this whole
witch-hunt was supposed to only be about
Trump Russia collusion that evidence
does not exist
all of this time now speaking of Russia
think about this with all that talk we
have another major breaking news story
tonight and that's the Russian president
the bad actor Vladimir Putin although
very that's right the guy that Obama
said wasn't a bad actor and twelve
Vladimir will have more flexibility
after the election remember that guy
he's claiming he has brand new nuclear
weapons that can penetrate America's
defenses now Putin made the announcement
during a state of the nation speech he
detailed how these new weapons literally
include a nuclear power cruise missile
and a new hypersonic missile and a
nuclear-powered underwater drone US
officials are casting a lot of doubt on
Putin's comments but saying that his new
cruise missile is still in the test
phase and has crashed a few times okay
now here's my point tonight you have the
liberal media and the Democrats
obsessing totally obsessed over a
conspiracy theory Trump Russia collusion
even though we have zero evidence Putin
every single day as we are doing this is
getting stronger
and the left and the media are literally
playing right into Putin and Russia's
hands now Putin's entire goal what is it
- so political discord in America and
that's exactly what the left that's
exactly what the media are literally
doing by going down the Russia collusion
rabbit hole with no evidence then
there's Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
remember Obama mocking Mitt Romney for
daring to call Russia a threat and then
ignored threats specific threats in 2014
from Devon Nunez and others on the house
Intel committee and he told President
Trump stop whining about the election
and election interference just days
before the election and Hillary Clinton
stupidly remember that silly reset
button she's gonna reset relations with
Russia and then she helped approve
giving Russia and Putin control of 20%
of our uranium and then she paid for the
Russian dossier filled with Russian
government lies you know so great job
media and Democrats you've done a great
job dividing the country and lying to
the American people without evidence
some pushing baseless conspiracy
theories because you hate Donald Trump
and Vladimir Putin is getting stronger
now we have more breaking news tonight
this story is outrageous
the Department of Justice is trying to
determine if the mayor of Oakland if she
literally obstructed justice warning
criminal illegal immigrants about ice
rates
now there's liberal mayor well she took
to Twitter on Saturday and to alter
illegal immigrants and warned them in
the Oakland area that hey federal
immigration authorities are preparing to
conduct operations now the acting head
of ice is blasting this mayor saying
that her stunt allowed about 800
criminal illegal immigrants to avoid
arrest and he also said this on Fox &
Friends this morning let's take a look
what she did is no better than a you
know a gang look out yelling police when
I when a police cruiser comes in the
neighborhood except she did it the
entire community I mean it's beyond the
pay I've been I've been doing for 34
years and this is a whole new law to
intentionally warn criminals that law
enforcement coming being a law
enforcement officer is already dangerous
enough but to give the criminals a heads
up that work
in the next 24 hours increases that risk
puts them you're talking about these are
American heroes I strap a gun to the hip
every day to defend this nation and to
tell the criminals were coming the next
24 hours it's just incredible beyond
incredible the mayor of Oakland is
literally aiding and abetting criminal
illegal immigrants and of course she is
defending her actions writing on Twitter
not talking about the consequences
I don't regret sharing this information
it's is Oakland's legal right to be a
sanctuary city and we have not broken
any laws we believe our community is
safer when families stay together okay
they did break laws we have laws on the
books it's pathetic but what the mayor's
not saying and clearly obviously doesn't
realize or care is that not only is she
putting immigration authorities lives at
risk she's doing the same thing for
American citizens in her community now
Isis saying all they're trying to do is
get the bad people off the street so
guess what if any of the criminal
illegal immigrants that should have been
detained commits a crime then the blood
will be on her hands and literally she
will be responsible for whatever happens
she owns this now we have a major update
to tonight on the Florida School
shooting Fox News reporting the
commanding officer we are now confirming
tonight on the scene dori Nicholas
Cruz's rampage literally ordered some of
the first responder deputies to set up a
perimeter instead of confronting and
neutralizing this madman this gunman now
this new piece of information is beyond
stunning now the Broward County
Sheriff's Office policy for dealing with
active shooter situations says first
responders may go into a building to
save lives without permission nepali
policy does not appear to mention
anything about setting up a perimeter if
that's the case and the question is why
did at least four Broward County
sheriff's deputies not rush into the
school like the neighboring community
Coral Gables officers did to save lives
now Fox News is also reporting that
there were delays and allowing EMTs to
go inside the school remember we're
talking about kids these literally these
moments precious seconds save lives and
we also know that there
dozens of Miss warning signs prior to
the shooting by the FBI and the Broward
County Sheriff's Office this is one huge
massive big government bureaucratic
failure at every level the government
failed the people of Florida and as we
have been telling you
Broward County Sheriff Scott Israel is
refusing to accept even an ounce of
responsibility and he's also saying that
he likely will not release video of how
deputies responded so that we you the
American people can see exactly what
happened shameful because the tragedy
could have been prevented